افادت شبكه ان بي سي نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان الانقسامات بين اداره بايدن
ونتنياهو بتت اكثر وضوحا منذ زياره بلينكن
لاسرائيل شبكه ان بي سي كذلك نقلت عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان نتنياهو رفض خلال
زياره بلينكن جميع طلبات واشنطن باستثناء
عدم مهاجمه حزب الله اللبناني واضافت شبكه
ان بي سي نقلا دائما عن المسؤولين
الامريكيين ان بلينكن ابلغ نتنياهو انه لا
حل عسكريا بشان مصير حماس وعلى اسرائيل
الاعتراف بذلك واضاف المسؤولون الامريكيون
لشبكه ام بي سي ان ادارات بايدن تتطلع الى
ما بعد نتنياهو لتحقيق اهدافها في المنطقه
المسؤولون الامريكيون كذلك اكدوا ان اداره
بايدن تحاول التحضير مع قاده اسرائيليين
اخرين لتشكيل حكومه ما بعد او حكومه ما
بعد نتنياهو ودائما نقلا عن شبكات ان بي
سي لمتابعه هذا الموقف الامريكي ينضم
الينا من الناصره محمود يزبك الخبير
بالشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد محمود
برايك ما هو الموقف الاسرائيلي من هذا
التوجه الامريكي الذي على ما يبدو انه
اكثر حسما واكثر جديا لمستقبل
غزه نعم يعني الموقف الاسرائيلي في هذه
القضيه وفي قضايا اخرى مثل ما راينا هذه
الليله على شاشات التلفزه الاسرائيليه وفي
الصح حفه هو موقف مرتبك وفي هنالك
انقسامات كبيره في داخل مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي يعني والموقف من هذه القضيه
التي طرحها بلينكن هو يشبه باقي القضايا
يعني الحارقه التي كان من الواجب على مجلس
الحرب ان يتخذ فيها قرارا ولا يستطيع ان
يتخذ قرارا بسبب ضعف رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
وارتباطه السياسي الكامل بالاحزاب
اليمينيه المتطرفه وهذه الاحزاب لا تمنعه
عمليا بشكل كامل ان يتخذ قرارا في بالنسبه
للحرب في غزه او بالنسبه للمخطوفين
الاسرائيليين المخطوفين في غزه ولذلك هذا
اي اي قضيه تطرح على للنقاش في مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي وهو المجلس الاهم لاداره هذه
الحرب اداره السياسه تكون دائما الاراء
متضاربه ولا ي ولا يتخذ فيها قرار وحتى
حينما يتخذ قرار يضطر نتنياهو ان يعني ان
ينقضه بنفسه دون الرجوع الى مجلس الحرب
حتى يرضي الاحزاب اليمينيه المتطرفه
الغاضبه سيد محمود نعم نعم ربما الابرز هو
ان ما ابلغه ال ان ما ابلغ به المسؤولون
الامريكيون لنتنياهو ان لا حل عسكري ل
بشان مصير حماس وعلى اسرائيل الاعتراف
بذلك برايك كيف ستتلقى في اسرائيل هذا
المطلب وهل ستقبل به
نعم هنالك
يعني كذلك في داخل مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
هنالك الشخص المعروف باسم ايزنكوت وايزن
كوت هو واحد رئيس اركان سابق في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهو من يعني من الحزب الذي
ينتمي لحزب جانس وايز كرت خلال الايام
الاخيره السابقه اكثر من مره صرح بشكل
واضح وعلى شاشات التلفزيون وفي كل مكان
هذا الكلام انه لا يمكن لاسرا لا يمكنها
ان يعني تستطيع الانتصار في هذه الحرب
ولذلك عليها ان تصل الى قناعه بانه لا
طريق امامها لا لاسترداد المخطوفين
الاسرائيليين الاسرى الاسرائيليين الا
بالتفاوض مع حماس انما يعني هذا الكلام
الفارغ الذي مثل ما هو قال يعني الكلام
الفارغ الذي يتشدق به رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه او وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بانه نضغط على حماس عسكريا اكثر من اجل ان
نصل الى حل بقضيه المخطوفين هذا هذا كلام
لا يفيد بشيء لانه يعني حينما يتحدث شخص
بهذا القدر في اسرائيل رئيس اركان سابق
ويقول لهم مثل ما يقول الامريكان الان
ويصرح بها علنيا معنى ذلك انه على المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ان يبدا بسؤال نفسه لماذا
يرسلوا ابنائهم ليقتلوا يوميا ويجرح في
غزه بينما هم يعرفون وقياده الجيش تعرف
انه لا طريقه لها للوصول الى انتصار عسكري
عليها ان تعترف هذه المره بفشلها العسكري
امام حماس وعلى ما يبدو انه هنالك اكثر
واكثر في المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي بدا
يعترف بهذه القضيه مثلما يبرز ذلك في
المقالات الصحفيه العديده التي بدات تنشر
في هذا الاتجاه